la presidenta Dina boluarte señaló que
existen intereses de diversos grupos al
margen de la ley como traficantes droga
personas dedicadas a la minería ilegal
al Contrabando y que están interesados
en crear un clima de zozobra ella ha
pedido que cese la violencia y ha
ordenado a las integrantes de los
diversos colectivos indígenas a que la
apoyen a buscar la paz a la reunión a la
unificación nacional y que se formen
mesas de diálogo pero estamos en medio
de una marcha nacional y antes de la
realización de esta he conversado con
diversos integrantes y ellos me dicen
que no van a parar hasta que la
presidenta tiene a boluarte deja el
poder Ellos están exigiendo la renuncia
de boluarte la destitución de los
congresistas la conformación de una
asamblea legislativa para que se
atiendan sus demandas sociales que
señalan
netamente dedicadas con la actual
Constitución a políticas neoliberales
Francisco cómo toma el pueblo peruano
este llamado de la presidenta porque
pues las protestas usted lo estaba
diciendo iniciaron pidiendo su renuncia
de hecho muchas personas nunca la han
reconocido como mandataria de Perú
en realidad existe un descontento con la
clase política y también con lo que se
denomina los diversos
organismos estatales se pide la
reivindicación de las comunidades
indígenas y del ciudadano el interior
del país que ellos denuncian que están
olvidados por el estado y las riquezas
que genera la minería la principal
fuente de riqueza extractivista no se
refleja en obras públicas
saneamiento en la mejora de la educación
y también lo que es la nutrición para
peruanos que viven en pobreza y pobreza
extrema en este país